[Music]
nature is here at cop26 our reporters
have been closely following all of the
tense climate negotiations
on the final day we sat them down to
discuss what they had found out and what
we should be looking forward to when the
final text comes in hello we're nature
reporters we are here at cop 26 in
glasgow it's the final day in my opinion
i feel like the atmosphere is really
electric today i've never seen anything
like it
was my first cop and what struck me most
is the very enormity of the event it's
been really overwhelming
it's partly perhaps because we've been
doing our jobs for the last 18 months
our normal reporting jobs from small
bedrooms little offices front rooms and
all of a sudden from doing that to being
thrust in this sort of ginormous
international
convention center has been quite
disorienting i would absolutely agree
it's huge it's overwhelming but you
don't really see any of that from the
outside there are so many things that
you experience when you're inside this
village that aren't really worthy of
inclusion in a news story but actually
all feeds into
that feeling of either
optimism or pessimism that you might
come away with and at the end of the day
just to interact with people who are
really trying to grapple with these big
problems um in all sorts of ways from
whether technology based or from the
perspective of social sciences or from
the perspective of science-based policy
uh it does help uh you know keep me in a
positive frame of mind
but i understand queer and you've been
talking to scientists who are here and
observing from the outside
what are they thinking about how this
meeting is going on
i mean the cop is by definition a
political meeting
and there's such a it is not a science
meeting
but still the issue of climate and
global change is now
an issue
that encompasses all science no
discipline of science can afford anymore
to ignore
the climate change challenges
that uh the world is is facing and the
scientists that you're talking to about
this meeting what would you say is their
feeling so far is it optimistic hopeful
skeptical
that depends of course on whom
you ask i have not experienced a lot of
you know deep-filled pessimism here
of course scientists
are well aware of the challenges ahead
but i think being scientists
they
already and and happy uh to facing these
challenges now essen i know you've been
looking into the climate justice side of
the equation i spoke to uh five maybe
six of the
researchers who were very involved in
the early 90s
in the rio earth summit and
they're a bit depressed
they feel that
the process
that they were all part of
set and train
um
many things
um which
have either been forgotten or they've
been deliberately sort of obfuscated and
avoided
one of those things is the question of
historical emissions
which we don't hear about and we haven't
really heard about so much in the cop
which is there was a study that we
reported on from the center for science
and environment in new delhi where the
researchers
added up all the emissions from roughly
the industrial revolution to now and of
course even
by the standards of
future decarbonization there's still a
whacking great amount that's occupied by
just seven or eight countries including
china but mostly what they call the
historic limiters
the argument they're making is that
there needs to be much sharper and
quicker decarbonization from the richer
countries in the next eight or nine
years otherwise the global carbon budget
just won't
accommodate
their industrial needs
and of course all the debate now here at
the cop is everyone has to decarbonize
and so they feel these architects feel
that
what they called common but
differentiated responsibilities everyone
has a responsibility but they're
different
that language
has gone historical emissions has gone
and that sort of concerns them
and what about the funding that we had
perhaps expected or planned to see flow
from the richer nations to the
developing world it's very likely that
there's going to be movement on funding
and there is a a pledge of 100 billion
the pinch point is that it's mostly
loans
which is not
what was envisioned back in the early
days of these processes was meant to be
that the phrasing was new and additional
not money that makes
poor countries even more poorer because
they get into debt so that's a worry
and there is talk also here of what they
call loss and damage it's really
a liability and compensation in the
event that a poor country you know has a
really hard time because of emissions
that it didn't do
but they don't use the phrasing of
liability and compensation because that
could open themselves up to legal claims
so they call it loss and damage
and there is language around loss and
damage in the text
i think the language of the agreement is
something that i've learned a lot about
which is that although these documents
are short they
lack
detail
each word each phrase is fought over and
is really important and i think
for from the outsider perspective
uh it might seem you know it might seem
a lot of discussion over what is really
a handful of sentences at the end of the
day but each one of those phrases
whether it be loss and damage uh or
something else can then be used uh
that's basically thin end of the wedge
that all the policy makers and decision
makers then use to push these decisions
forward so what key phrases do you think
we should be looking for either in their
presence or their absence
in the discussion i know one i was
looking for
was in uh decarbonizing transport uh
there was a lot of
discussion over whether active travel
which basically means cycling and
walking and not just electric cars would
make it into the discussion and did make
it as a little note at the end so what
can we tell our readers to look at oh um
i would say
two maybe three so look out for coal so
at the moment uh there is text
that
is saying something to the effect of
coal being phased out
um there'll be all kinds of caveats to
that then there's the uh the double f
word
fossil fuels this is in the context of
subsidies in the sense that there may be
a call for subsidies public subsidies
fossil fuels to be phased out now some
countries particularly the oil producing
states a country like saudi arabia or
iran for example parts of the u.s
russia it's the public sector that
essentially is the owner of the fossil
fuel industry so you could argue that by
definition that is entirely a subsidy
so if you keep the word subsidy in there
then their economies like crash
overnight all that so that's what their
worry is
of course everybody will look for
specific commitments financial
commitments and commitments as to
the speed of decarbonization
but as long as
governments are unable to tell us how
they will actually achieve their
ambitions
scientists and the general public will
tend to think that anything what
governments may say is is but lip
service so a term that i've learned
during this cough is this term non-state
factors so we've been talking about uh
funding for coal for fossil fuels uh
subsidies uh this is all really within
the public sphere but there's a renewed
focus on the decarbonization that has to
happen in private industry and
corporation now i know the u.n has
announced a couple expert panels where
researchers are going to be providing
oversight can you tell us a bit more
about that so yeah so this is in the
context of an announcement by business
businesses are
saying or claiming uh that potentially
many many tens of trillions of dollars
will move from
their existing investments into what
they are calling netzero investments
so what the un has gone and done uh they
have they announced more or less the
same time that they would set up um some
scientists who would start to assess and
evaluate what these commitments really
mean in practice
it's very early days they haven't even
announced the names of the scientists
we're trying to find that out that
information now but that's where we are
but outside of these halls where we're
sitting there's a lot of
um
suggestions such as green washing my
feeling is that most scientists would
be rather cautious about
you know the benefit of
setting up just another
expert panel of course it is important
to have to get people to talk with each
other and have scientists among
the people
tasked with making decisions
but don't trust on panels so
the big question
is cop 26
going to move the needle
on climate change
and if so to the extent that it's
necessary
assad
um
yeah it will move the needle um question
is how far and how fast
um so there's all to play for in the
next 24 hours next 24 to 48 hours but
then there's also a long game after i
mean in a way the real work happens
beyond uh beyond this uh this meeting
and what do you think we're in are we
gonna be walking out of the door
celebrating tomorrow morning
um yes and no um
this
cop was not a game changer nobody
expected this i guess the challenge
ahead now from a from a scientific
perspective
is to
bring together the various sciences
and to make them
work
and act upon the problem in a meaningful
way um and how
this might happen when so many
disciplines are involved is an open
question but there's growing interest
among scientists and there's enthusiasm
among scientists to tackle the problem
so um from
a scientific
point of view i think we can leave this
meeting with some uh optimistic feelings
i mean i will chime in that i have been
trying to
see what's going on outside the
conference center as well as inside and
for me
we absolutely cannot ignore
all of the people who are not maybe
coming through the security gates but
are very very passionately engaged with
what's happening here and
i think that the impact of these
activists
really can't be overstated in terms of
how
uh how the decision makers are
responding there's a feeling that the
decisions that they make will directly
impact their own careers and that's i
think what is very motivating for people
so
for me the
whatever happens inside the walls
there's a fundamental change going on
outside the walls as well that hopefully
will contribute to
positive movement going forward